merci madame la présidente madame la
députée à nividal je vous remercie pour
votre question qui met le focus en fait
sur deux exigences la première c'est de
bien accueillir tous les visiteurs et
tous les athlètes à Paris lors de ses
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques pour
réussir ses jeux la deuxième c'est de
permettre que les personnes en situation
de handicap et toutes les personnes en
situation de handicap est un accès plein
et entier à tous leurs droits et
l'accessibilité est bien entendu le
sujet majeur et l'enjeu majeur pour
notre pays et la mise en accessibilité
alors les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 c'est un
formidable une formidable opportunité
pour progresser et travailler à
améliorer ce qui est quand même assez en
retard dans notre pays il faut bien le
reconnaître et se catalyseur doit être
un catalyseur pour cet accessibilité des
espaces publics des services publics et
des Services numériques puisque
numérique est un enjeu également
important l'autre catalyseur aura été et
est la Conférence nationale du handicap
ou le président de la République a fait
de l'accessibilité une priorité et
engager l'État à hauteur de 1 milliard 5
sur les 5 ans à venir avec notamment un
fond d'accessibilité pour les
établissements recevant du public de
cinquième catégorie nous travaillons à
structurer les modalités pratiques
d'accès à ce fond il faut qu'elle soit
simple nous travaillons également avec
Amélie ou EDA Castéra et Olivia Grégoire
à sensibilisé les acteurs du tourisme
les artisans les commerçants afin que et
bien eux aussi fassent une priorité de
cette mise en accessibilité et se font
les aidera et enfin je voudrais quand
même dire pour conclure que la dynamique
elle doit se passer à l'échelle du pays
entier car il est inadmissible qu'au 21e
siècle les personnes en situation de
handicap vivent encore des
discriminations en lien avec le manque
d'accessibilité des espaces et des
espaces numériques et de nos services
publics